as kanye west continues to publicly slam
his estranged wife kim kardashian's new
beau pete davidson it is what it is a
source tells et how the saturday night
live star is handling the drama and
bonding with the kkw beauty founders
famous family
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
just to get you up to speed the 44 year
old grammy winner has been trashing pete
on social media most recently on
thursday posting and then deleting two
posts aimed at the 28 year old comedian
the first this screenshot of pete on snl
wearing a make kanye 2006 again hat yea
asks in the caption quote hi skeet you
got any more mental health jokes for me
the rapper also posted this clip from
the same 2018 sketch where pete weighed
in on kanye giving an impromptu pro
donald trump speech to the saturday
night live audience after his
performance on the show a week earlier
kanye i know you're like yo this is the
real me i'm off the meds
take him
no shame in the in the medicine game i'm
on him great
take him there's nothing wrong with take
him if i ever got on a plane and the
pilot said i just want all you to know
this is the real me flying
i jump out
being mentally ill is not an excuse to
act like a jackass
kanye captioned the clip in part quote
this is not harassment this is payback
so is there anything kanye can do to win
you back yeah um there is and i'll tell
you in a way that kanye understands i
made this uh make kanye 2006 again now a
source tells et that pete is trying to
stay out of the drama between the rapper
and the reality star
adding that he's been trying to
disassociate from kanye as much as
possible and ignore his rants
pete knows it's not his place to be too
involved even though he is being dragged
through the mud he doesn't care he just
wants to be there for kim and support
her he genuinely cares so much about her
and their relationship
i love that energy in my life and
another relationship pete cares about
the one he has with his girlfriend's
family so cool e.t source says that kim
and pete have gotten even closer in the
last few weeks and the king of staten
island star has been going out of his
way to connect with kim's family in his
own subtle ways and he wants to show
them who he really is quote he wants the
family to know that it's not just a
fling between him and kim and that it is
way deeper than that he has been trying
to establish his own individual
relationship with them i love that and
pete he's not just talking the talk he's
walking the walk check out this post
from kim's sister chloe revealing the
funny guy sent her flowers on
valentine's day it's such a beautiful
thing and when e.t chatted with kim's
bestie jonathan cheban earlier this week
he weighed in on their love
i think it's cool you know what she's
having fun i guess you know uh you know
i i've hung out with them a couple of
times and you know i love her to death
so whatever whatever makes her happy
[Music]
you